you've talked a lot you're on record
talking about the quite rapid process
through which Innovative Tech startups
become kind of grumpy enmeshed
incumbents
um both just with the state and more
generally in their business practices
um that topic has come up a lot recently
with the Twitter files and you know the
sort of Revelations of the ways that
companies
um collaborated with uh willingly I
think in many cases but maybe with a
looming threat as well
um with government agencies around
misinformation and other questions
um it seems to me like we're going to be
in for more of that that this sort of
blurring of the lines between public and
private is Our Fate
um is that what it looks like to you and
if so you know is that ultimately a
thing that threatens Innovation or are
there ways in which it could potentially
speed things along
yeah so you know look the textbook view
of the American economy is that it's uh
you know it's a it's a free it's free
market competition and like you know
companies are fighting it out and you
know different toothpaste companies are
trying to sell you different toothpastes
and it's a you know largely competitive
market and then every once in a while
there's an externality that requires
government intervention and then you get
you know these weird things like you
know the too big to fail Banks or
whatever but you know those are the
exceptions to the general working in the
free market system
you know like I can tell you my
experience having been now in startups
for 30 years is that the opposite is
true
um specifically that James Burnham was
right
um that we passed from you know the
original model of capitalism which he
called Bourgeois capitalism which is
what we still think capitalism is we
passed into a different model which he
called managerial capitalism uh you know
some some decades back
um and the the the actual correct model
of how the US economy works is it is
mostly a process of oligopolies cartels
and monopolies
um and they most it's it's mostly them
you know for it's basically big
companies forming up in an oligopolis
cartels and monopolies
um and doing all the things that you
expect oligopolis cartels and monopolies
to do
um and then they jointly basically
corrupt and capture the Regulatory and
government process and so they they end
up controlling their Regulators
um and so most sectors of the economy
are a conspiracy between the big
incumbents and their putative Regulators
um and the purpose of the conspiracy is
to perpetuate the long-term existence of
those monopolies and cartels and to
block new competition
like so
so that's what that's where I've come
out on
um to me that completely explains the
education system both K-12 and the
College University system it completely
explains the Health Care System it
completely explains the housing crisis
it completely explains 2008 the
financial crisis and the bailouts it
completely explains the Twitter files
like I think that's precisely what what
has been happening in Tech
um and so if you're if you're if you're
if you're if you're open to that
interpretation of how the world works
and how the country works and how the
economy works then like a lot of things
start to make a tremendous amount of
sense
um and then you know I think that what
the Twitter files is is it's basically
an x-ray of a specific instance of that
happening
um which and this is just factual what
we now know from the Twitter files is
that a very large number of people in
government by the way some of them
political and you know some of them like
politicians but also some of them
bureaucrats right and so some of the
members of the right deep state right
which either you know as we know the
Deep State either does not exist or if
it does exist it's good right one or the
other
um um I think most people yeah that's
what I've heard there's a recent book on
that that apparently makes that case
very very clearly
um so let's just say like the permanent
bureaucracy or again what James Brennan
would say is like the managerial class
in government right the sort of
permanent uh Cadre of Professionals in
government who basically manage
everything
um and you know those people and then
also people on the outside who they fund
as their proxies right with government
money with taxpayer money right have
been exerting enormous pressure
um on Twitter
um to block sensor dot dot dot dot you
know and and you know what looks to me
like a straightforward constitutional
case for a deprivation of constitutional
rights you know first fourth and fifth
amendments
um in a way that is clearly illegal both
under the Constitution and under uh is
it uh uh Title 18 uh whatever 242 uh you
know there's a specific federal law that
says there it's a felon it's a felony
for a government official to use the
power of being in government uh to deny
citizens of constitutional rights
um there's actually by the way another
law there's 241 that actually applies
that same principle to private citizens
including private companies
um and so I think it's possible that
there has there actually I think it's
possible that there's actually been
criminal activity both on the government
side and on the company side
um and yeah and it's just like yeah
that's been happening and you know the
Twitter for every new drop of the
Twitter files shows that that's what's
what's been happening you know in a in a
in a non-political world where we all
just like read the Constitution um you
know this would be a constitutional
crisis you know this would be the
biggest story in the country there would
be hearings you know there would be you
know among other you know immediate
impeachment proceedings like you know
this this would be a five alarm fire
right because obviously the government
can't be allowed to do this
um you know in our in our in our in the
real world of course that's not what's
happening
um and you know and we're back to either
either denial or or Embrace under the
theory that this is good and proper
right
um are there sectors that are less
subject to that Dynamic that you just
described in which the startup quickly
become the incumbent semester of the
state
I mean look so I think it's so my my
theory basically is it's the question is
always the same question like is there
actual competition right like so so
actually I think there's like a deeper
my deeper idea here is basically the
process of evolution like so the idea of
capitalism is basically an economic form
of the idea of evolution right a natural
selection I mean you know survival of
the fittest and the idea that basically
it's a superior product ought to win in
the market
um and that markets ought to be open to
competition and a better you know a new
company can come along with a better
widget and take out the incumbents
because it's widget is superior and
customers like it better and so like for
evolution to proper to to function
properly you need survival of the
fittest which means you need things to
die when they're not the best thing for
capitalism to work properly you need the
same thing to happen you need companies
to die when they are inferior to other
companies that are doing things better
right that that you know that's that
that's sort of inherent to the to the
thing and so the the question always is
like is there actual competition
happening or not right is is and you
know in part is like do consumers
actually have the ability to freely
select among the existing Alternatives
and then the other question is like can
can new can new products actually come
to market right you know can you can you
actually bring a new widget to Market or
do you get blocked out because the
regulatory wall that's been established
is you know basically makes that
prohibitive I mean look the great
example of this is is banking right
where you know the big thing in 2008 was
we need to bail out these Banks because
they're quote unquote too big to fail
and so then there were screams of the
need to reform the too big to fail banks
that led to Dodd-Frank the result of
Dodd-Frank I call it the big Bank
protection act of 2011. uh right the the
result of that is that the too big to
fail banks are now much larger than
before
um and the number of new Banks being
created in the US has dropped to zero
right because it's now effectively
impossible to launch a new bank in the
U.S because you know JPMorgan Chase has
10 000 lawyers right working on their
regulatory issues and you have one like
it's it's not possible like you can't
start new Banks anymore
um and so anyway sorry so I'm I'm
repeating the uh I'm repeating the case
against um so but the question is like
where is that not happening like you
know where where in the where in the
market is that actually not happening um
you know where is there free in open
competition you know look the the
cynical answer is this it's not that
doesn't happen in the spaces that don't
matter right like so toys like anybody
can bring a new Toyota market like it's
fine sure great right anybody can you
know I don't know like anybody can open
a restaurant right it's I mean I just
say don't matter being like you know
these are fine and good like you know
consumer categories that people really
enjoy and so forth but as contrasted to
the healthcare system or the education
system right or the housing system right
or the legal your business if you want
freedom your business better be
frivolous I mean that would be that
would be the cynical way of looking at
it like if if it doesn't matter from a
societal structure right in terms of
like determining the power structure of
society and basically the power of the
government and Society
um then yeah go crazy do whatever you
want but like if it actually matters to
like major issues of policy right where
the government is intertwined with them
then of course it doesn't happen there
and again it doesn't happen there not
just because of the government it
doesn't happen there because of an
intertwining of the incumbents in the
government
you know look I I think this stuff is
good look this is one of these things
where I almost have trouble debating it
I'm not debating with you but like
debating it with people who argue with
me on this because I think it's so
self-evident it's like well why aren't
there you know it's like why are all
these universities like identical like
why are all of the major universities
implementing the exact same like crazy
like why do they all have like identical
ideologies right why isn't there like
why isn't there a Marketplace of ideas
at the University level right and it's
like well that becomes a question of
like why aren't there more universities
okay well and I can tell you why there
aren't more universities there aren't
more universities because to be a new
University you have to get accredited uh
the accreditation
um uh Bureau is is run by the existing
universities
like it
it's sitting there in plain sight I'll
give you the other another example why
do Healthcare prices do what they do
right why why do Healthcare prices work
the way that they work a major reason
for that
um is because
um they because basically they're paid
for by Insurance um there's private
insurance and public Insurance the
private insurance prices just key off
the public prices because Medicare
basically drives the whole thing because
Medicare is the big buyer
um so how are Medicare prices set
they're set by a unit inside HHS called
CMS
um and uh and CMS runs literal
soviet-style price fixing boards uh for
medical goods and services
um and so once a year there are doctors
who get together in a conference room at
like a high in Chicago somewhere
um and they sit down and they establish
they fix they do the exact same thing
that what was the unit of uh the the
Communist Party in the in in Russia that
used to do this in the Soviet Union
um there's a term for it was the central
price fixing Bureau
um right so the Soviets had a central
price fixing Bureau it didn't work we
don't have that for the entire economy
but we have that for the entire
Healthcare System
right and it doesn't work for the same
reason that the Soviet system didn't
work right and so we've exactly
replicated the Soviet system we're
expecting better results it operates in
plain sight you can go on the CMS CMS as
a website they'll explain this all to
you it's operating in plain sight
everybody thinks it's a great idea and
then you know lots of people are calling
for you know increased government you
know centralized you know control and
purchasing of healthcare which would
make that system stronger and so it's
like we we know that this is not going
to work we know that it's going to only
result in restrictions of supply and
Rising prices we know precisely what the
outcome is going to be we seem perfectly
happy with it and then we complain about
it so